ankle stiffness awesome for a running
back awesome for anybody who's
accelerating
notice how he gets his little pump going
all of this is
isometric all the core is isometric look
at the
incline press position hey there guys so
i've got something
cool and a bit different for you today
we're gonna have a guest
video from honorary bioneer and
recent contributor to the channel jc
santana he's also one of the absolute
luminaries of functional training
someone who's been around
since the beginning of this movement so
he really knows what he's talking about
he has tons of exciting ideas and he
works at the institute of human
performance
we get to test all of them in a real
world setting on
top athletes on special forces and on
regular
folks so yeah he has lots of awesome
stuff to contribute and if you do find
it interesting then be sure to check out
jc santana
at his youtube channel you can see that
flashing up on the screen right now i'll
also put a link to it in the description
down below today's going to be talking
about car pushes
truck pushes or sled pushes and how they
can be an excellent
tool in your arsenal particularly if
you're interested in running faster
jumping higher and uses this as a
vehicle no pun intended
to talk about some of his philosophies
regarding the specificity principle
and how this compares to something like
the squat it's really interesting stuff
so
check it out and let me know what you
think of course i'll be back as usual
very soon with more of my regular stuff
i'm going gonna be doing a video on the
mind muscle connection
gonna be doing a focus on one of my
favorite exercises and i've also got a
video coming on the one punch man
training because it has been hotly
requested since the
backy training video really took off so
without further ado
i'll hand you over to jc
all right when we're talking about
specificity we got to look at
specificity from a broader
perspective a lot of the
traditional exercises that we use in a
gym do produce
power do produce strength do develop
strength and power
however you got to look at the mechanics
okay
if you look at the squat at the deadlift
good mornings
high cleans all of the olympic lifts one
of the things you see
is flat footed you see everybody
wiggling the toes driving from the heels
a lot of hip hinging huge flexion in the
hip
huge flexion in the knee and huge
dorsiflexion all right
also often times you're squatting deep
deep deep into the hole
that you know is very difficult it gives
you great muscular development
however if you look at specificity
running walking cutting all of that is
not that if you look at the angles of
the hips
they're relatively small angles the
torso is usually
upright especially when you're trying to
jump in uh volleyball when you're trying
to jump in basketball the torch is very
high
when you're accelerating in football
rugby and all that you can have a lower
torso however
although there may be hip flexion you
got to look at the amount of knee
flexion
okay and ankle flexion it is not
what we think of when we're squatting
lunging doing step up
it's and none of those traditional lips
when you're looking at uh generating
forces from the heel
and flat foot it especially when you're
running and you're jumping
it's not that way it does not pan out
that way
actually when you're running out
everybody knows it's from the ball of
the foot especially during the
acceleration phase
but also when you're jumping when you
have a lead jump
okay whether it's one legged or
two-legged
the final takeoff and the huge transfer
of forces
occurs at the ball of the foot which
requires ankle stiffness
at about 90 degrees and this is very
very obvious when we're doing
exercises that are extremely functional
that we like like the car push
or the sled push it is very specific to
human locomotion it is very specific to
sports speed
and sports acceleration and it's a lot
more specific
than the traditional lifts that we are
used to using
in all of the gyms so when you're
looking at trying to develop
athletic prowess athletic lungs athletic
legs power endurance and the right
biomechanics that are very very
forgiving
on the body you have to consider
exercises like
the truck push and the sled push
now once you get the biomechanics out of
the way and that's very easy because all
you have to do is
look at videos and look at the best look
at the best in sports when you look at
videos
and you'll see that those best in sports
are usually not very strong in a gym
their bodies are really not you know uh
very muscular or
hugely muscular uh i'm thinking of colby
i'm thinking of michael jordan
i'm thinking of uh lebron james i'm
thinking of muhammad ali in a different
sport
a multitude of uh of athletes that
are lean all of the martial arts lean
some are fast some can jump some are uh
fast twitchy
others have endurance out the wazoo and
none of them are impressive
in the gym yet they're hall of famers so
my question
is what what
characteristics what genetics
what abilities do these people naturally
possess
that are not developed in a strength gym
okay that allow them to do their sports
at the highest level
that's number one number two what kind
of training
do i need to acquire some of these
characteristics because
if the characteristics i'm looking for
belong to people that are not really
gym goers or gym
buffs or gym elites okay
they just kind of go to the gym and do a
little something then
why am i killing everybody in the gym to
try to get these characteristics the
people who have them
are not in the gym and if they are it's
just basically
maintenance and light training so that
leads me to
what kind of strength are we developing
how much strength is enough
how heavy are we going and more
importantly what
damage is that heavy heavy banging
causing us in the fourth and fifth
decade of life
so when you look at the biomechanics you
look at the characteristics of elite
people
versus people who try to earn those
characteristics by strength training
and the idea that the more strength
training we do the more of these
characteristics we are going to acquire
and so the impetus and the motivation
for going heavy
heavy and abusing your body is there why
in pursuit of the characteristics
which have a huge genetic component
that's not acquired in the gym
so when you look at the biomechanics
when you look at the amount of work when
you look at the style of training and
you look at the intensity and volume of
training
and you look at the last 10 15 years
look at the people in the nfl look at
the athletes in the nfl look at the
athletes
in in in sports and you're seeing hip
replacement hip replacement shoulder
replacement hip replacement knee
replacement
then you have to say is the training
that we're doing especially the heavy
training that we're doing
to get or develop the characteristics of
that some people have
naturally is it worth the wear and tear
is it worth artificial joints when
you're 40 and 50 years old
okay is it worth it and is it needed
because even if it's worth it if it's
not needed that means you can be great
at your sport
without tearing your body up then we
have to look for that then we have to
look for that
and that's why one of the things that we
have done here at ihp
is start substituting okay some of these
big big lists that have the tendency to
be abused like cleans deadlifts
squats good mornings and start looking
at
alternatives that are more effective
with less time in and
definitely less wear and tear and when i
tell you more effective
for sure because you cannot argue with
the specificity principle and you can't
argue with the biomechanics
that again can be seen squat which is
normally used to run
faster and jump higher versus
the truck push versus a sled push
which we can do the same with
less less wear and tear the joint angles
are
a lot more forgiving and the kinetic
chain
works a lot more naturally the loads are
not as aggressive
and boy can you really get in great
shape
and develop awesome legs and awesome
upper body
using the truck push and the sled push
all right so let's narrow this to five
great reasons why
we do truck pushes number one it looks
so cool it looks so cool there's no way
you're not getting a high schooler or a
college athlete even a pro athlete and
you're putting them behind a navigator a
hummer
or or any other car and you say we're
gonna do truck pushes and they're not
gonna go wow
okay cool it's not gonna happen okay
that's number one number two
specificity if you look at the bipedal
action one leg at a time
uh ankle stiffness knee flexion
dorsiflexion
acceleration angle if you look at all
the things that we want especially
in running down the field or down the
court it doesn't beat it number three
it's only concentric which is huge
because
it's the eccentric that gives you the
muscle tear
that causes the dawn and that causes a
lot of strength gains
however we have the kaiser runner which
is concentric eccentric concentric and
man that gets you tired
and that makes your legs sore it makes
your hamstring sore it makes your glutes
sore
but the car push rarely
makes you sore why because when you come
up and it's eccentric back in here and
in the quads
you're not on the ground you put your
foot on the ground and then you push
so it's positive positive positive huge
huge benefit because the delayed on
muscle soreness from car pushes are
almost non-existent number four
it involves the entire body because here
you're pushing
everything is tight and your legs are
pumping so here you are look man if you
get tired with a squat
okay you you better have a spotter more
deadlift you better have a spotter or
you better have a rack
if not you're in trouble you get tired
with a car push you slow down you get
really tired you stop
so the safety perspective is immense but
the entire bodywork
is also incredible you're pushing with
your hands your core
is tight everything here is
isometrically
stabilized and your legs are pumping if
you do short
inertial pushes like like we like to
call them
no cardio just leg power if you do one
one circle around our parking lot you
have a minute
20 a minute 15 and it is
grinding and number five it's a real
life movement
heaven forbid if your car breaks down
it's always good and this happened to my
sister her car broke down
she pushed it off the road and people
were like wow this woman got behind her
car well
she's used to pushing a navigator alexis
ain't no problem
so it's a real life movement if you're
pushing a refrigerator it's kind of the
same thing
if you're pushing furniture is kind of
the same thing again the fact that it's
a compound
real life movement is one of the
greatest benefits of the card push
you cannot not consider this modality of
training
another fantastic thing about the car
push especially on
our parking lot is that you can
periodize it people don't think you can
periodize
um a sled or a car push well
we have five yard what we call inertial
pushes
which is just to get the car moving so
it goes from a dead stop
to maybe five yards and that is your
strength
that is your hardcore movement then we
have eyes
which downhill which gets you going it's
almost like an acceleration
uh training right and so you can use
that acceleration training during
your conditioning you can use the
inertial pushes during
strength then when you take your
inertial pushes you push that card
really hard for
five to ten meters and then you break
into a sprint
you can rest a minute or immediately
break into a sprint
and that neurologically activates your
central nervous system and then deloads
the sprint so you can get more power
that's your power phase okay we already
said the strength phase is the inertial
the long uh 15 20 second phases are your
conditioning
and last your power endurance phase man
you can just do
an entire parking lot and we're going to
show you
how unique the parking lot at ihp is all
right
we even have little uphills that we use
for strength training over 10 meters
so depending on what you're doing with
the car the landscape
and the topography of the parking lot or
the street that you're in
you can use your car for speed
strength power and power endurance
alright so
don't miss this incredible type of
training
all right let's see one of the best at
ihp
do the car push gilbert burns soon to be
the welterweight champion of the ufc all
right here we go
he's always happy and this is what i
want you to see
look at this ankle stiffness
awesome for a running back awesome for
anybody who's accelerating
notice how he gets his little pump going
all of this is isometric all the core's
isometric look at the
incline press position of the shoulders
core stiffness core stiffness look at
the angle of the
knees extremely forgiving i don't even
i don't even think that he goes to 45
degree of knee flexion
his torso is although leaning forward if
you see the torso
relative to the femur in other words how
much
um how much hip hinging is there not
much
positive positive see he went down this
is all down the hill and now he's going
to go up his first hill
so the topography of the ihp parking lot
has all of these challenges
now when he's tired he's got to go
uphill soon coming
down a hill and this teaches you when it
starts to get
easy and you're tired don't go easy
that's when you got to push because you
have to create
enough momentum coming down the hill to
tackle this
uphill and this teaches you when the
thing gets going that's when you gotta
push look at that his heels have never
touched the ground
he's kept his body nice and flat the hip
hinging at the
at the um hips are is minimal he's still
there with a partial knee flexion
all isometric in the hands finishing his
uphill
and now he's gone over the uphill he
turns when he turns
those tires really bite down on the um
on the uh on the on the concrete and you
can see
he's done and that is the car push at
ihp
you